in 2015 a case came before the United
States Supreme Court involving a
same-sex male couple that had been
living in the state of Ohio
couple John Arthur and James obergefell
had gotten married in Maryland and soon
after that Arthur had died
Ohio law defined marriages the union of
one man and one woman and the state
refused to recognize the marriage in
Arthur's death certificate
oberga fell sued and the key question
that confronted the Supreme Court was
whether a state's decision to prohibit
same-sex marriage violated the U.S
Constitution
underlying that question however were
more fundamental ones that our nation
has struggled to address since its
earliest days
how should the Constitution be
interpreted who decides its meaning
and what if anything does the
Constitution have to say about issues
the framers didn't directly address and
in many cases couldn't have possibly
anticipated
Mr obergefell contended that Ohio's
same-sex marriage prohibition violated
same-sex couples fundamental right to
marry and their equal protection right
under the 14th Amendment to be treated
the same as opposite sex couples indeed
he argued that the very purpose of
Ohio's marriage ban was to impose
inequality and stigma on same-sex
couples
Ohio responded that the constitution
leaves this policy decision with the
states and their voters
the people of Ohio want to adopt
same-sex marriage the state argued
that's their prerogative but the
Constitution says nothing about same-sex
marriage and certainly does not dictate
marriage policy to the states
and a landmark 5-4 decision called
obergefel V Hodges the court sided with
Mr obergefell and implicitly same-sex
couples Across the Nation
it reason that a person's choice about
whether and whom to marry is among the
most personal and important decisions of
a person's life
finding that the denial of the right to
that decision would violate both the
equal protection and due process causes
of the 14th Amendment the Court held
that the state could not
constitutionally deny same-sex couples
the right to marry if they wish
in one of four dissenting opinions Chief
Justice John Roberts acknowledged the
appeal of the majority's arguments from
a policy standpoint but emphasized that
the court is not a legislature
judges therefore should not decide cases
based on what they think is good policy
but rather based on the Constitution
in his view the Constitution quote had
nothing to do with the majority's
decision
how do you feel about the Court's
decision
we'll take up the case in more detail in
a later lecture but as you might imagine
people on both sides feel very strongly
about it the intensity of this
disagreement is characteristic of
disputes over constitutional issues
generally from abortion to affirmative
action to the scope of federal power to
Presidential Power in times of war and
more
in fact the great policy debates and
culture wars of our time are often waged
as battles over constitutional meaning
why
because the Constitution is the
blueprint for American government
setting the rules by which politics
operate the stakes are therefore very
high
the most Americans throughout our
history have never actually read it
we've been arguing about the
Constitution since it was written
as of this taping there are movements
underway to change the constitution in
fundamental ways their proponents who
include both conservatives and liberals
argue that a new Constitutional
Convention should be held to fix a
variety of perceived problems and the
ways our government and Society function
is that a good idea
to answer that question properly and to
understand American government politics
and law we must understand how the
Constitution Works how it has been
interpreted and why we have the document
in the first place
so that's what we're going to explore in
this course starting with the
Constitution's origins in the 18th
century
in the year 1786 the United States was
in crisis the young country had won its
independence from Great Britain with the
end of the Revolutionary War in 1783 but
its problems were far from over
states which had been allied with each
other in the war against England now
were becoming bitter rivals they
quarreled over a variety of important
issues
for example the states disagreed about
the proper rules for commerce between
their borders
States enacted laws that aided their own
citizens but they disadvantaged other
states and citizens from those States
when conducting trade or business
states with big ports for instance could
not resist taxing goods from nearby
States nearby States still had to use
the ports to sell the goods but they
tried to retaliate in other ways
minors began to come to a head when
negotiations between Maryland and
Virginia over fishing and trading rights
in the Potomac River grew into an open
invitation to all the states to meet at
Annapolis Maryland's capital in 1786.
as it happened delegates from only five
states showed up and they concluded that
they couldn't accomplish much without
more States represented so they put out
a call for a broader meeting the next
year in Philadelphia
that meeting would become the
Constitutional Convention of 1787.
by the time the delegates met in
Philadelphia it was clear that the
Articles of Confederation which had
taken effect in 1781 were insufficient
to govern the young country
in a nutshell the Articles of
Confederation provided for only a very
weak central government which was unable
to manage either disputes between the
states or the various external and
internal threats the nation faced
for example under the Articles the
Confederation Congress could not impose
taxes and National Defense and
prosperity had suffered as a result
lacking the money for a decent army or
navy America found itself in the
mid-1780s at the mercy of foreign
pirates marauding on the high seas this
made International Trade more difficult
closely related to the issue of taxes
was the issue of debt
in part because of its inability to tax
the Confederation Congress had taken out
large amounts of debt to finance the
Revolutionary War
still lacking a source of Revenue
America was unable to pay back its loans
this seriously threatened the nation if
America developed a reputation as a
country that did not repay its debts it
would find it very difficult to borrow
money in the future and borrowed money
was vital to a growing economy
moreover foreign countries to which
America owed money might go so far as to
treat non-payment of debts as grounds
for War and the American continent was
still a tempting Target for European
Empires searching for new lands to
conquer
America faced several other external
challenges to the National welfare in
the wake of the Revolutionary War
American Merchants were eager to restore
pre-war patterns the bulk of which
included trade with England itself and
English colonies in the Caribbean but
Britain's still angry at the colonies
promptly closed its Harbors to American
ships both on the British Isles and in
the Caribbean meanwhile British ships
sailed into American Harbors bringing
Goods that had been missed during the
war
many countries would have imposed large
taxes on British ships or simply closed
their ports in response
the Confederation Congress lacked both
the power to tax and to regulate either
Interstate or foreign Commerce and the
states of course were not coordinated
enough to issue a set of restrictions
themselves
all this made it impossible for American
ambassador to England John Adams to
negotiate a satisfactory commercial
treaty with England
already had what it wanted so why
negotiate
another Foreign Relations issue to
confront America after the war concerned
the peace treaty itself
after War had broken out many states had
confiscated property owned by British
subjects or loyalists the Treaty of
Paris of 1783 required the Confederation
Congress to recommend that the state's
permit British subjects and Loyalists to
sue for the recovery of confiscated
property
in the meantime however the state
governments that had confiscated the
property often had sold it to third
parties placing the weak Confederation
Congress in the awkward position of
guaranteeing what it lacked the
Constitutional power to deliver
the British used the non-compliance with
the treaty as a pretext for retaining
their fourths in Upstate New York and
Michigan which they also were supposed
to abandon under the terms of the treaty
this further jeopardized the plans for
Americans to move westward in part
because the British encouraged Native
American tribes to resist American
encroachments on their land
still another Foreign Relations problem
involved the territorial Integrity of
the young country
Spain controlled New Orleans in the
1780s and in 1784 it closed the city and
the lower part of the Mississippi River
to American navigation
this made life extremely hard for
settlers and Farmers living west of the
Appalachian Mountains
previously those settlers had shipped
their produce and goods down the
Mississippi River and into the Gulf of
Mexico and that way kept up trade
relations with the rest of the American
states on the East Coast this was easier
than traversing the rugged mountains
with their goods
Spanish action isolated those settlers
and Spain apparently hoped to bring them
under Spanish control thereby helping
solidify Spanish control of the region
discouraging further migration west of
the Appalachians and protecting Spanish
Silver Mines in Mexico
the young United States lacking military
and diplomatic clout could do little in
response
on top of all of this was internal chaos
the most famous example is shae's
rebellion in Western Massachusetts
shae's Rebellion grew out of an economic
depression Massachusetts suffered in the
mid-1780s as it was still trying to pay
off its sizable wartime debt the state
government located 125 miles away in
Boston was imposing heavy taxes on
farmers in Western Massachusetts to try
to pay off its creditors most of whom
lived in the Boston area
times were already tough for the farmers
some of whom had spent time in debtors
prison
correctly or not they thought that the
courts tend to decide with the wealthier
creditors when the farmers refused to
pay the new taxes the state took them to
court and the courts ordered their Farms
seized
infuriated the farmers organized their
own militia of 2000 troops led by Daniel
Shea's some of these Rebels surrounded
courts around Western Massachusetts so
that the courts couldn't open and order
more Farms seized
State militia that was called out to
stop the rebels refused to do so and in
some instances even joined them
the Rebel's next goal was the first
National Armory in Springfield which
held cannons muskets and Gunpowder the
rebels marched through one of
massachusetts's worst Winters and
managed to cut off the roads to the
Arsenal on three sides they pledged to
kill any prisoners they captured
as this internal crisis intensified the
Confederation congress met in New York
to authorize the recruitment of federal
troops to restore order in Massachusetts
however refused to pay for federal
troops this only deepened the problem
the central government had proven unable
to suppress what was becoming a major
domestic uprising
realizing they would receive no help
from either their own State militia or
congress Boston's wealthiest men pooled
their money and underwrote a state force
of 4 000 men
these Fighters joined with State forces
and defeated the shades Rebels after
pursuing them through the snow for a
week
Shea's rebellion was over but it still
had enormous political impact
about a decade after the Declaration of
Independence Americans were fighting
against and killing other Americans
it was not just strangers fighting each
other but neighbors fighting Neighbors
and government had been unable to cool
tensions beforehand or suppress the
uprising once it arose even in
Massachusetts which supposedly had one
of the best state constitutions
something had gone terribly wrong and
Americans all over the country took
notice
their governments had failed them
it was against this backdrop of multiple
and interrelated governmental failures
that the delegates met in Philadelphia
in the summer of 1787. the states had
sent their representatives to revise the
Articles of Confederation but many of
the delegates believed that the Articles
were Beyond repair
that an entirely new Charter of
government was necessary they therefore
began debating the contents of a new
constitution even though such a
departure from their initial mandate was
a lawless action
from the start it became apparent that
the delegates could not agree on much
two disagreements dominated the
convention
first involved the question of how
States would be represented in Congress
many delegates assumed that states would
have proportionate representation in the
House of Representatives meaning that
states with larger populations would get
more Representatives than states with
smaller ones
what about the Senate
some delegates such as James Madison
believe the Senate too should have
proportionate representation
others especially from smaller States
believe that each state should have the
same number of representatives in the
Senate
as you surely know the Constitution
ultimately provided that each state
would get two senators but the delegates
would debate the issue over and over
again
second was the question of slavery
some Southern delegates insisted that
the constitution provide ample
protection for slavery and they got
their way
the Constitution that emerged from the
convention prohibited Congress from
abolishing a slave trade for 20 years
stipulated that runaway slaves be
returned to their owners even if they
had managed to flee to a state without
slavery
and perhaps most notoriously it provided
that each slave be counted as
three-fifths of a person for purposes of
a state's representation in the House of
Representatives
as a result states with large slave
populations got disproportionately large
representation in the house and through
the electoral college system and
presidential elections as well in other
words those slaves did not enjoy the
right to vote their presence meant that
White Citizens and slave states who did
enjoy the right to vote got increased
representation in the federal government
this Arrangement helped the southern
states further entrench slavery in the
decades to come it was not until the
13th amendment abolished slavery in 1865
at the end of a brutal and long Civil
War that the Constitution's pro-slavery
Provisions would be undone
it's interesting to note that the
framers didn't spend a lot of time
debating many of the issues we care
about most today
for instance they said very little about
individual rights they said very little
about the power of the federal courts to
review the constitutionality of
governmental action they also didn't
come to much agreement on the power of
the U.S president
moreover they rarely reach consensus on
the issues they did debate
as a result the final document was very
much a compromise that most delegates
agreed was imperfect Madison himself
sometimes called the father of the
Constitution was disappointed by several
features of the Constitution including
the convention's decision not to give
the federal government a veto power over
state governments
by its own terms the Constitution could
only take effect if nine of the 13
states ratified it
during the ratification debates that
followed throughout the country it
became clear that there was widespread
disagreement not just about whether to
adopt the new constitution but also
about what it meant
these debates foreshadowed centuries of
disagreement to come
while the Constitution left many
important issues unresolved it was
clearly designed to serve some primary
purposes
we might disagree about how it serves
those purposes but it's worth
identifying what those purposes were
first and foremost the Constitution
establishes a national government and
allocates power among the branches of
that government
Article 1 creates Congress and confers
upon it enumerated legislative powers
this Congress is bicameral meaning it
contains two houses
Article 1 sets the qualifications for
each House's members and also generally
defines the procedures for enacting laws
Article 2 creates the presidency and
gives it the executive power
defines the office the qualifications of
the occupant the method of Elections and
the powers of the presidency though it's
very vague as to the scope of executive
power
article 3 creates the U.S Supreme Court
and authorizes congress to create lower
federal courts
it also specifies the categories of
cases over which the federal court shall
have jurisdiction
note that the creation of a national
government was a big deal in 1787.
as we've already seen America's national
government under the Articles of
Confederation had very limited powers
and even lacked a chief executive and a
federal judiciary
while the crises of the 1780s convinced
many Americans that they needed a
stronger central government than the
Articles had provided for the shift from
the very weak decentralized government
under the Articles to the stronger
national government under the
Constitution signaled a major shift in
American political life
it's therefore no mystery why the
Constitution did not vest Federal power
all in one place
although the framers realized that the
Articles of Confederation had gone too
far in decentralizing power they also
remembered English colonial rule well
enough to view the centralization of
power as a means to tyranny
to the framers King George III of
England had tyrannized the colonies and
he had been able to do so in part
because no other branch of government
possessed sufficient power to balance
the king's vast Authority although
Parliament behaved tyrannically too
partially as a reaction to their
experience under English rule the
framers created a constitutional system
in which multiple branches must act to
accomplish any result
for example to enact a law both houses
of Congress must pass a bill and the
president must sign it unless the
legislature is able to override an
executive veto by a super majority which
is difficult and doesn't happen very
often
and if Congress enacts a criminal law
enforcement requires prosecution by the
executive branch and conviction within
the Judiciary
a second thing the Constitution does is
sketch the relationship between the
federal and state governments ours is a
Federalist system meaning that we have
two kinds of governments National and
state with jurisdiction over the same
territory there was already a federalist
system in place under the Articles of
Confederation of course but Power
resided almost entirely within the
states
framers recognized that there were
certain governmental functions that
could be performed much better by one
central government rather than multiple
different states
in particular they thought a national
government was necessary for defending
the country for relations with other
countries for a national currency and
for the regulation of national Commerce
but the framers still left much power
with the states themselves
where in the Constitution can we see the
balance the framers actually struck
between National and state power
well Article 1 grants Congress certain
enumerated powers it says quote all
legislative powers here and granted
shall be vested in a Congress of the
United States
thus if the Constitution does not Grant
Congress a specific power Congress lacks
that power
of course subsequent amendments to the
Constitution added to congress's power
most notably the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments which were adopted between
1865 and 1870 after the Civil War vested
more power in the national government to
enforce new Rights created by those
amendments
thus these reconstruction amendments as
they're known altered the original
balance between the state governments
and the national government
but even taking these changes into
consideration the Constitution defines
congress's Powers rather than leaving
them open-ended
also the 10th Amendment stipulates that
the powers not delegated to the United
States by the Constitution or prohibited
to the states are reserved to the states
or to the people
so if we read these two principles
together we get the rule that
congressional action is only valid if
the Constitution authorizes it and that
state action is valid unless it's
prohibited
in other words under our constitutional
system Federal action is presumptively
invalid and state action is
presumptively valid
however it's also worth noting that once
federal laws are properly enacted
article 6 of The Constitution makes
clear that those laws are the supreme
law of the land and Trump any state laws
to the contrary
so the federal government has more
limitations on the kinds of laws it's
allowed to make than do state
governments but the supremacy clause
stipulates that when in Conflict valid
federal laws Supreme over otherwise
valid state law
a third major goal of the Constitution
is to protect individual rights
as I mentioned earlier the original
Constitution said very little about
individual rights most of the important
Liberties that many Americans consider
core constitutional rights Free Speech
free exercise of religion freedom from
unreasonable search and seizures and so
on they were added to the Constitution
as the Bill of Rights The Constitution's
first ten amendments which were ratified
in 1791.
that's not to say that the constitution
completely ignored individual rights
before the Bill of Rights but it didn't
protect much
this absence of individually protected
rights in the constitution of 1787 may
seem surprising but some framers believe
that the protection of specific rights
was unnecessary because the very
structure of government protected rights
in other words they understood that the
checks and balances they were building
into government separation of powers
bicameralism federalism those existed to
protect individual rights from the
excesses of government
moreover these Americans were quick to
point out that their system of
government was decidedly different from
that of England
had its Magna Carta from 1215 and its
Bill of Rights from 1689 and both those
protected some individual rights but in
England Parliament was Sovereign so the
people needed explicit protection from
The Sovereign from the country's
governing powers
but as the founding generation came to
see it in the United States sovereignty
resided not in the government but in the
people themselves
the people sent their representatives to
government but in so doing they did not
cede sovereignty to the government
consequently a Bill of Rights was seen
by many as irrelevant
of course ultimately a Bill of Rights
was added to the Constitution in large
part because many states that ratified
the Constitution did so on the condition
that a Bill of Rights be added
in fact the Bill of Rights was really
offered in part as a political
compromise to appease Anti-Federalists
who were fighting against ratification
in many states and wanted additional
assurances that government would not
become tyrannical
some members of the founding generation
also recognize the potential for tyranny
of the majority and saw the Bill of
Rights as an additional Safeguard
against that tyranny
bear in mind however that the Bill of
Rights of 1791 was much more limited in
scope than the provisions that so
pervade our constitutional Consciousness
today
indeed it originally only applied to the
federal government meaning that the U.S
Constitution's Bill of Rights did not
protect against State governmental
infringement of these rights many states
had their own Bill of Rights in their
own state constitutions
but most of the rights in the Bill of
Rights were much later applied to the
states through the 1868 14th Amendment
but in many cases that did not occur
until well into the 20th century
one final note about individual rights
almost all constitutional rights protect
people from governmental action not
private conduct The Only Exception is
the 13th Amendment which prohibits
slavery including of course slave
holding by private individuals
otherwise however constitutional rights
only involve the relationship between
the government and individuals not the
relationship between individuals
individuals are protected from each
other by private laws such as tort law
and contract law but government action
is required for the Constitution to
apply
of course the Constitution empowers
government to pass certain laws that
apply to private conduct but for the
most part the Constitution does not
constrain private conduct by its own
Force
so those are the major things the
Constitution does
as you can see it's not so hard to
summarize the Constitution's primary
purposes and Broad strokes but that
doesn't mean it's easy to figure out
what outcomes the Constitution requires
in particular cases
For Better or Worse the Constitution
often doesn't speak for itself
sometimes as in the case of obergeophile
V Hodges that we considered earlier
issues arise that are not directly
addressed by any constitutional
provision
in other cases The Constitution's broad
open-ended language raises questions as
to when they should apply
what does due process mean cruel and
unusual punishment
equal protection privileges and
immunities
even when the Constitution is written in
absolute terms most people agree that at
least with regards to individual rights
it usually does not function in
absolutes
circumstances matter
the First Amendment for example is
written in absolute terms and prohibits
Congress from making any law impinging
the freedom of speech
but Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
famously said that falsely shouting fire
in a theater and causing a panic is not
protected and most people would agree
that the right to free speech though
crucial in a free Society must have
certain limitations
lawyers and judges are therefore left to
argue about how best to interpret the
Constitution
historically they have drawn in a
variety of sources including the
Constitution's text and structure
judicial precedent original
understandings past governmental
practices practical concerns moral
concerns and more
as you might expect lawyers and judges
frequently disagree with each other
about not just how to decide particular
constitutional cases but also about
interpretive methodologies
probably not surprising then that the
U.S Supreme Court decides a lot of
high-profile constitutional cases like
the same-sex marriage Case by a five to
four vote
the open-ended nature of the
Constitution's language can make
constitutional law maddeningly uncertain
I think you'll find though once you
sweep away all the nuances and
complexities it usually boils down to a
single question
who decides
who decides the meaning of the
Constitution and the content of
governmental policy
the federal or the state government
the courts or the legislature or the
Executive Branch the people themselves
and if so how do we figure out what they
think
some combination
if it's a combination who is the final
word when there's a disagreement
over the next 11 lectures we will
examine numerous constitutional cases
and doctrines we'll dig into the weeds
of some famous decisions and legal
reasoning
as we do so I suggest you keep in mind
this question of who decides because at
the end of the day constitutional law is
usually not about which policy is wisest
or which values are most American or
morally acceptable
no constitutional law is about power and
specifically where power resides in
American government and whether a
particular governmental entity has the
authority to do what it's trying to do
it is similarly about whether and when
courts have the proper authority to tell
a governmental entity that it may not do
what it's trying to do
and it is about how judges other public
officials and ordinary citizens should
think about and frame these questions
unpredictable or elusive as the answers
May sometimes be they matter enormously
because they govern our individual
liberty our governmental structure and
the character and future of our nation